[Music]
hi everyone so I have two disclaimers to
make in this talk so the first one is
that I'm actually be criticizing a bit
of JavaScript at a JavaScript conference
and the second one is that it's my first
start so you have to thank you so these
two things means you don't have to be
extra patient with me so my talk is
gonna begin with an anecdote about how I
was writing a very simple function so I
was working on this project which was
for managing time off for employees so
basically had to displace in some kind
of table when employees were starting
the vacations so it's basically coming
down to writing the simple function
which we would take a list of employees
and get their starting location date for
each one and this of course work great
for a few days until someone made some
changes I was not aware of and I was
starting to get errors like this and so
at this point I made what I think most
lazy programmers do which is start
adding some defensive checks so we had
this function and now we're just
checking that employees was he fine hi
I'm sure most of you have done this at
some point so again we had this and
obviously some time later we get cannot
read poverty bla of now so someone was
passing an array but it had the wrong
kind of thing
so at this point I'm pretty tired of
this so I got basically every check I
can surf function starts to look like
this we check if employees we find and
we check that each employees defining
has this method and only thing we call
it and just in case if everything fails
we are that we are gonna return an empty
array so
this is kinda what our function looks
like now so we're just pretending that
whatever we're getting is fine when
obviously it's not but again we're not
too proud of our code but we're pretty
sure that should work now obviously it's
hours later we get a call from QA and it
tells us that while the table is
rendering its rendering blanks for the
date and just to prove them wrong we
find this line we plug our debugger and
obviously we get this so at this point
I'm sort of like the ISM and he actually
made me question my relationship with
JavaScript until I could admit it to
myself so I was like I love you
JavaScript but we have a problem well
you have a problem or rather many
problems so welcome to my talk this is
called the young JavaScript demos a
languages for the modern web history
story but higher I want out and
discovered new languages to right front
and obligations so the first obvious
choice is of course typescript so
typescript most of you may know is a
type server set of JavaScript didn't
this means that every J's problem is a
valid typescript program and this allows
us to slowly add types to our problems
to start gaining some of the benefits to
start catching some of the mistakes
before we're at production so if we go
back to our original example the top
function is what we wanted to write and
the bottom one is what we have to
because we couldn't control what people
were doing with it
so in typescript there's a simple
solution so first we define a type for
employees in this case it's just going
to be an object with the required gate
vocation they method and notice
then in the implementation of our
function the body didn't change at all
we just added some annotations for the
arguments and the return-type and so if
we go and check the cases that were
breaking our function like passing null
or passing an array with malformed
objects they're gonna be compile time
errors so type scripts can I know that
and they're not gonna they're gonna it's
gonna reject our program because it has
the wrong types so we don't actually
have to go and and test it out in the
browser to get sure it works so just to
talk a bit more about typescript I think
it's a great solution when you have a an
existing JavaScript code base and you
want to start adding some types getting
some of these benefits or when you want
to start adding new features with a bit
more safety when refactoring stuff like
that but I was not convinced it was the
best solution for when starting a a new
app I thought maybe there were other
choices that could get us a better
return in the dock but some of the
problems being a superset of JavaScript
means it carries many of the quirks and
problems of it and also it has a really
complex or a complicated type system
because it has to accommodate to all the
patterns were using javascript and we do
some crazy things with it we sometimes
we have a function sometimes return an
array sometimes returns numbers and and
this means that types in typescript
sometimes can get really hard to
understand to write and to read because
of this we have a relatively weak type
inference so type inference is the
ability of the compiler to automatically
detect and assign types through our
problems so do we we can save up some
annotations but in typescript that
breaks quite easily if we use some of
the advanced features of the language
and finally this is improving a bit
recently but it usually has some pretty
are the error messages so when we're
doing something wrong
it's kind of hard to correct so this
property need to investigate more
languages and I found out that there are
lots so this is just a bit of at least I
found on github of languages that
compile to JavaScript nowadays so I
picked two to total today which are fine
found really interesting the first is
gonna be closure or closure script which
is a language that encourages functional
programming
it has immutable data structures by
default with opt in materiality it is a
dialect of Lisp and it really has great
tooling and it's been battle tested for
years on the server side - it compiles
both to JavaScript and JVM bytecode so
it's really super fast so one of the
crazy things have a closure is that it
has really minimal syntax this is
basically all you need to know to start
writing the language so here I have some
examples the first one is a function
call so to call a function you simply
open parentheses type the name of the
function and the arguments separated by
spaces the second one is calling the
same function with more arguments we're
defining a constant we're defining a new
function and finally we're defining a
list so closures has this crazy property
that if we look at how we define lists
it's pretty much the same as how we make
a function call so the only difference
is that for a function call will require
that the first element in this space
separated things inside parentheses is a
function but apart from that closure
gives the gives us this ability to kind
of seamlessly think of code as data as
it does code so if we look at this
deeper we'll see that this expression we
can kind of think of it like the blue
side down as being calling the function
+ with 3 + 4 by the
who uses prefix notation for everything
or we can think of it as a list which
has the first argument
sorry the first element being a function
and the other elements being the numbers
3 & 4 so this is pretty mind-blowing and
this is actually one of the core things
that but a very powerful system of
macros of metaprogramming said we can
use this enclosure to write code that
writes code so i would really love to
get into details about this and show
some examples but I don't have enough
time I really recommend you read this
blog post about sorry by Paul Graham
which is a co-founder of Y Combinator's
in which he explains how he used another
dialect of Lisp to beat their
competitors by David being able to
deliver tech faster and better and he
explains some of the use cases for this
meta programming features and so now I
want to talk a bit about um
is a programming language it's also a
functional language which has static
types it is immutable only which means
there is absolutely no need to be lit in
the language all functions are pure it
obviously combusted javascript and
here's one of the most interesting
things that it has no exceptions no
runtime errors and no an undefined
simply don't exist so to get a bit
familiar with the syntax here we'll have
how would how you define an if
expression in them so everything is an
expression you know that means that
everything has to evaluate to some value
so for example an if expression always
have has to have an else branch because
if the condition is false it has to
return something and that's why it's
more similar to say the ternary operator
in JavaScript and a if statement and
then we have how you define a function
so you notice there's no function
keyword any
like that and arguments are separated by
spaces both for calling and defining
functions this one only returns its
argument x 42 and so I am only see as I
said the language is specifically built
for writing single page applications and
like react uses a virtual Dom for
rendering HTML but contrary to react we
have no special syntax for actually
rendering these these nodes all we have
our functions will see for example in
the app function which in react we are
using this component which only has
which only displays a div with an h1 and
discuss some component you know it's
just a function div which takes two
lists the first one being the list of
attributes here we're giving it a CSS
class of up and the other list is the
list of children this of course both are
equivalent in both render is super cool
app so diving into the code to talk
about bit about this which is um has a
standardized way of building
applications which is called VM
architecture so if you use redox or
something like that this is completely
similar fact some of those libraries are
based in part on this where we have if
you function which is a a function which
takes the current state of the world
that is called the model and returns
from HTML we have messages which are
like real extractions and we have an
update function that given the message
that was triggered and the current state
of the world returns a new the new state
so for example here is a quick show of
how you define this for things did they
say a simple simple counter application
so we're defining a
initial model which is just an integer
it's gonna be the number zero will
define the types of messages we can
trigger which are going to be increment
and decrement and your update function
we handled what happens with those cases
in the case is some increment with just
returning the model plus one and the
case of decrement would decremented by
one the model and finally a view it's
going to be just ativ which renders
three elements Ibarra with a text of -
that's gonna reduce our counter and
we're doing that by binding this event
handler so that's saying that whenever
the button is clicked is going to
trigger the message decrement and the
other button is pretty much the same
thing so if we actually go and check
this out this is exactly the same code
we have our simple counter up yay and so
what it's very interesting about sorry
if uses the compiler not a problem till
to yell at you when you're wrong but
more like an assistant when calling
going coding so I want to show it about
how coding feels like numb so we've got
this simple application which is the to
do and we see up you'll notice here that
it has the common completed and active
filters so now we get that requirements
have changed and we actually don't want
to show that anymore but once we show
filters for when tasks are hard and when
tasks are easy and from management they
tell us that a task is hard when it has
a description longer than 15 characters
okay so we go ahead and implement this
so it's not necessarily to understand
the syntax but the process
so having to know that here are I'm
defining these types
which shows me which are the filters
that I got having in my application so
that's the first thing I'm gonna do oops
so I'm gonna change completed by complex
which are gonna be hard tasks and
incomplete by simple so I just say that
and I'm gonna let the compiler guide me
so I'm gonna go and fix line by line
what it tells me is wrong so it says
line 78 I cannot find this thing this
name seemed close enough okay so I think
I see complex which is what I want
change it and this is how I'm gonna
render it I'm gonna render it to us hard
now it's not finding incomplete again
I'm gonna change it to simple render a
cc again I have a similar error aligned
303 it's simple and here's when I'm
gonna be handling the logic of how when
I actually want to render a to do when
the filter is simple so so I said oops
so as I said I want to when the filter
is simple I want to render it to do only
if its description is house less than of
equal to 15 characters so I'm gonna take
the list and the length of the
description when I check this I'm gonna
save and I'm gonna keep fixing my errors
so what happens if I get some typos in
here okay you're good enough to be a bit
better but if I do this I still have
some other errors so
this is funny example because this is
what URL I'm getting when I switch to
some filter for example when I was in
the incomplete filter I was in the slash
active URL this is something that
perhaps could have been easy to it
pretty hard to spot if I didn't have
these kind of checks okay so now it's
giving me the error about the typo that
I got before so this this message is
actually fantastic because it says these
two records does not have a this
description field
this is usually a typo here are the to
do fields that are most similar and
finally it says so maybe description
should be description and that's exactly
what I want so I go ahead and change
this one funny thing is that I have
never gone into my browser yet okay so
now finally it compiles successfully so
I go and I'm gonna check okay this is
hard it works it's just easy it works
yay thank you
[Applause]
so this is just a bit of the experience
you get when you have a really helpful
compiler I recommend seeing that talk I
linked which compares even more the
experience of versus react which is
pretty interesting and finally I want to
talk about some of the things that I
missed which he studies lightning fast
this is kind of outdated but some
versions ago at least and was faster
than any major JavaScript framework so
that's pretty interesting and it's super
lightweight so this is the size of the
real world up and this is in part
because assam has only pure functions
doing things like tree shaking is
extremely easy and you can tree shake
and eliminate a lot of code some other
interesting things that al has is that
it has out-of-the-box support for
building bundling time travel debugging
and cetera and this is actually super
cool that it has automatic a.m. and
forced semantic versioning so when you
when you're publishing a new package
version the compiler is going to check
that I you didn't change any of the
publicly exported functions at Gd and
change any of the types and if you think
it's going to tell you this is a my
major change so you have to one bumped
that version so upgrading dependencies
is super safe so that's pretty much all
I had finally few words about myself I'm
a consultant I really love functional
programming and I think it can improve
the world of software development so I
do consulting on Haskell and Scala so if
you're interesting that please come talk
to me and that's it thank you very much
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]